hey Brett bear it's your favorite hour  before yours the five-hour before yours  also the favorite anybody  congratulations on 10 years thank you  I've never been invited to be a guest on  your all-star panel I'm not going to  take that personally hopefully 10 years  from now I'll maybe make it yellow I  remember 15 years ago when you rushed up  from Atlanta to help with 911 coverage  and ever since then you've been like a  rocket and we so appreciate special  report and I have been on the panel  Jesse thanks for having it yeah I think  rationality counts a happy Anniversary  Brett it is an honor one of the honors  of my career to be on your panels thank  you I remember when I was on the panel  because she's a good egg we have Greg  nice panel Brett was Jesse what does  that mean anyway happy Anniversary happy  ten years we truly care about our Bret  Baier  [Music]